hey leute und willkommen zu einer neuen
snapshot vorstellungen von den snapshots
5 b 38a und jetzt kommt ihr sohn hütchen
eingelaufen hallo hühnchen auto es ist
schon relativ spät heute abend aber ich
habe es früher nicht mehr gebacken
gekriegt hat irgendwie vorzustellen weil
ich keine zeit hatte
aber ich versuche das jetzt mal eben
nachzuholen zwar wollte ich euch ganz
kurz die änderungen vorstellen und die
sind diesmal ziemlich cool eigentlich
also nicht wieder so blöde bugfixes und
alles sondern die sind echt interessant
und zwar wurde ein neutraler mob die
fledermaus hier hinzugefügt die kann man
bisher nur mit so sachen spawnen mit
diesem spot on bett heißt fledermaus
oder sportage ist hexe dazu komme ich
gleich oder die treten auch in höhen und
ganz dunklen orten auf die tun nix wenn
ihr die schlag passierte auch nix wenn
ihr getötet stirbt stirbt kommt noch gar
nichts außer ich glaub nicht mehr
erfahrungen ja nicht nur erfahrungen
dann gibt es die hexe die sport bisher
auch noch nicht die gibt es bisher
einfach nur so hier kann man so hier
einfach hinsetzen
die greift einen mit wurf trinken an
also wenn man die schlägt bzw greift
dennoch glaube ich einfach so an dich
finden gerade im trade off mode deswegen
seht ihr das nicht begreift ein entwurf
trinken kann also die hat seine hand
seht ihr und den wird die dann auf mich
und wir schon seht habe ich paulson gift
du solltest einfach weggehen weil du
nervst grad einfach interessieren und
ich weiß noch gar nicht wie genau man
die tötet oder diese nicht noch keine
fakten in minecraft wird irgendwie
zusammen gesammelt worden weil die
ganzen dinge wurden halt einfach
hinzugefügt also wie zum beispiel
fledermaus und hexe und mehr darüber
auch nicht gesagt aber die hexe zweck na
ja also das zu den mops dann wurde der
bacon zu der bieten blog widmen die
kommentare geschrieben dann kann die
diesmal dazu geschrieben haben wurde
hier die dinge verändert die eu
diese strahlen nach oben und die textur
wurde auch ein wenig verändert den ball
blog habe ich ja schon man im extra
video erklärt dann wenn man nun in den
netz geht geht das alles viel viel
schneller das seht ihr schon hier ich
bin hier gehe ins portal rein und bin
sofort wieder hier in der welt finde ich
sehr interessant
dann wurden außerdem ganz ganz viele
neue sounds hinzugefügt von c4 18 und
zwar neue sounds beim platzieren von
holz da kann ich mir mal ganz kurz hier
holz schnappen
wenn ihr ganz genau hinhört also das
sind schon andere stars ich kann das mal
ganz kurz ein bisschen lauter herstellen
die sounds sind schon ein wenig anders
und finde ich allgemein mittlerweile
besser also von holz steinen sand kies
pflanzen leiter wasser lawa das haar
leiter entfällt hatten alles mögliche
auch von kühen schweinen und auch hier
vom wasser sound wenn die teile da so
hoch und runter ging sind dann ist das
sehr interessant
sodann weil ich einfach was zeigen was
ein bug ist und zwar wenn man unter
wasser abgetötet machen die keine
geräusche das war jetzt über wasser da
musste ich mir mal ganz kurz jeden
gesunden schwein holen das pack ich mal
hier hin
irgendwie macht geräusche
naja also vorhin haben die keine
geräusche gemacht als sich die
unterwasser getötet habt müsst einfach
mal selber ausprobieren und das war es
eigentlich schon das einzige was jetzt
noch gekommen es ist das wenn man
baumstämme zum beispiel hierzu drauf
selbst auf setzlinge oder so von oben
dann kommt die so wenn ich allerdings
jetzt irgendwie wieder hier die daran
setzte dann zeigen die auch nach oben
und wenn ich die weiter als die mittel
hier
dann bleiben die so wenn ich die da so
drüber dann gehen die auch so also die
dieses komplette setzen ist ein wenig
verändert worden mit diesem schräg und
so das ist alles ein bisschen anders
geworden muss man selber herausfinden
was genau das ist habe ich jetzt noch
nicht so viel gebrauch von gemacht dass
oder links auch noch ein bisschen
verändert und außerdem sind da hinten
ganz viele creeper aber der kommend blog
target parameters wird verändert und
zwar gibt es da weitere informationen
minecraft wiki dass er total komische
zahlen dann kann ja auch nicht viel
anfangen also das einzige was ich
wirklich erklären kann sind diese sachen
der rest ist mir relativ unbekannte dazu
gibt's doch nicht so viele informationen
ich hoffe euch hat das video gefallen
ich würde mich über
eine bewertung freuen positiv wenn es
euch gefallen hat negativ nicht gefallen
hat und dann würde ich sagen schreib mir
doch mal in die kommentare was sie am
coolsten fahndet dann sehen wir uns beim
nächsten mal gysi